[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing a topic
near and dear to the Harry Potter Story
magic within the greater wisting World
Magic flourishes at every turn
captivating readers and transporting
them into a world of wonders from
spellbinding duels to extraordin
enchantments The Wizarding World
exhibits an extraordinary amount of
mystical potential at times the
capabilities of magic even seem
boundless however looking beneath the
surface of this magical tapestry lies a
fascinating question what are the
limitations of magic forget what magic
can do let's instead focus on what it
can't do taking this approach I think
we're in for a much shorter list let's
dive in gamp's law notice discussion
surrounding the limitations of magic is
complete without first addressing gamp's
law of Elemental Transfiguration a
magical law within the Wizarding World
that governs the rules and limitations
of
transfiguration I should also point out
that law in this context refers to a set
of scientific principles and not a piece
of prohibitive legislation in the Harry
Potter Universe conjuration is a form of
transfiguration magic that involves the
summoning or creation of objects
creatures or subst es through magical
means it is a branch of magic focused on
materializing things out of thin air or
transforming existing objects into
something else and according to gamp's
law there are five principal exceptions
as far as what can be created out of
thin air your mother can't produce food
out of thin air no one can food is the
first of the five principal exceptions
to gamp's law of Elemental
Transfiguration it's impossible to make
good food out of nothing you can summon
it if you know know it is you can
transform it you can increase the
quantity if you've already got some as
shown above the first known principal
exception to Camp's law is food however
what's interesting is that even though
the law prohibits creating food from
scratch it does allow for food to be
transformed multiplied or altered
through Transfiguration magic and though
we know food to be number one on the
list of five principle exceptions to
gamp's law the other four remain
unpublished in official wisting World
law
however this does leave the door wide
open for theories and I happen to have a
few exception number four gold given
that gamp's law seems to be centered
around conjuration I think it's
reasonable to infer that the other four
exceptions were simply other categories
of substances which could also not be
created from nothing based on what I
know about witing Society I suspect that
one of the other main exceptions is
somehow related to money or gold this
would explain why in the flourishing and
plentiful Wizarding society and poor
witches and wizards exist and also how
Wizarding poverty could exist at all I
can't imagine that the Weasley family or
RIS Lupin were poor by choice and it's
important to note that even witches and
wizards would need some form of
incentive to work so I think that the
inability to conjure currency fits quite
well here it's also likely that the
exceptions with gold were deeper rooted
than food as if gold could be multiplied
as F could be then it still wouldn't
really be any kind of an issue being too
lazy to multiply your own gold is not
exactly an excuse for being poor so I
imagine it's just not a possibility
furthermore if it was possible to
transfigure things into gold then the
Quest for the fabled philosopher stone
which does just that wouldn't have been
going on for centuries exception number
three life I strongly suspect that
another one of the exceptions to gamp's
law is Conjuring life at first first
glance there are a few instances in the
series that would contradict this like
herione being able to conjure a swarm of
birds however it's important to note
that these conjured animals are not
truly alive but rather intricate
replicas of Life while they may appear
remarkably real they lack the ability to
grow reproduce or go through a life
cycle thus they do not violate gamp's
law as they are not considered living
beings furthermore the ability to
conjure living objects such as animals
would apparently conflict with another
aspect of gamp's law which prohibits the
conjuration of food for instance even if
one were to conjure a transfigured
chicken it would merely be a replica and
provide no nourishment if butchered and
consumed furthermore one of the
underlying themes of Harry Potter is
that no matter how you choose to go
about it death is an inevitability
cheating death is simply not possible
and I feel that creating artificial life
would somehow undermine this messaging
exception number two love in the Harry
Potter series love is a powerful and
recurring theme it is depicted as a
force that transcends magic and
influences the actions and relationships
of the characters it's also portrayed as
a driving force that can conquer evil
protect loved ones and Inspire acts of
bravery and sacrifice so given the power
of love it seems a fitting exception to
gamp's law however I suspect your minds
may now be deviating towards a specific
potion Amenia AKA The Love Potion
amortentia is the most powerful love
potion in the world it is distinctive
for its mother of pearl Sheen and steam
rises from the potion in Spirals and
Malena smells different to each person
according to what attracts them and
while Amenia may be labeled The Love
Potion there is an important distinction
that needs to be made here you see while
amentia mimics love and induces powerful
infatuation it does not create genuine
love just a semblance of love that is
derived from strong Obsession real love
is not something that's achievable via
magic and this is reinforced by slug
horn himself exception number one
knowledge information the realm of magic
includes the ability to manipulate
thoughts memories and emotions while
altering thoughts and memories is
considered a legitimate form of magic
techniques like legilimency and oomancy
do not fall under the purview of
Transfiguration this is because thoughts
are intangible and spiritual in nature
not physical substances Transfiguration
on the other hand deals with the magical
alteration Conjuring and manipulation of
physical objects as a result thoughts
cannot be modified created or erased
through the use of
transfiguration furthermore although it
is possible to enhance one's
intelligence acquire knowledge improve
cleverness transfer information from one
mind to another and generally manipulate
what one knows finding a ready-made
Solution by waving a wand is not
possible while there are tools such as
correcting feathers and answer writing
quills their abilities are limited in
certain ways otherwise characters like
Dumbledore could effortlessly obtain
vast amounts of information about Tom
Riddle in an instant or create entirely
new spells within moments therefore
while it is possible to gather
information and increase one's
intellectual capacity it remains
impossible to conjure information out of
thin air and those five would be my
guesses for the exceptions to gamp's law
food love life love and knowledge
however the exceptions outlined in
gamp's law are certainly not the only
limitations to Magic in reality there
are many other things that magic can't
accomplish let's dive into some more
aging the process of aging and the
desire to Hal or reverse it is a
recurring theme in fiction but in the
Harry Potter Universe magic does not as
far as I can tell serve as a means to
control or manipulate age witches and
wizards do have various
superphysiological benefits when
compared with humans such as a slower
rate of aging and or longer lifespans
but stopping or slowing aging with magic
doesn't seem possible all too often we
have witnessed Wise Old Wizards with
white beards trailing down to the floor
and to suggest that this could be
controlled with a bit of magic seems
unlikely however no conversation
surrounding aging would be complete
without mentioning the philosopher stone
or more specifically the elixir of Life
The Elixir of life was a potion created
from the philosopher stone by Nicola Fel
that extends the taker's life both
Nicola Fel and his wife took the potion
for most of their lives and it allowed
them to live upwards of 600 years old
however the long-term effects of the
philosopher stone are largely
undocumented whether drinking the potion
could truly result in eternal life is
not known the potion does suggest that
witches and wizards have some degree of
influence over their rate of Aging but I
would classify use of the rare and
sought-after philosopher stone to be a
bit of a one-off resurrection the act of
resurrecting the dead is portrayed as
highly complex and near impossible in
the Harry Potter Universe while there
are instances of characters returning
from apparent death such as vort and
Harry Potter these cases involve unique
circumstances and Powerful Magic
Resurrection is not a common or easily
achievable feat and even when attempted
it comes with significant risks and
consequences if the tale of the Deathly
Hallows is anything to go by then we
know that death is an inevitability and
that attempts to cheat or circumvent
death are futile this is reinforced
through use of the Resurrection Stone
which only brings back shades of the
former individuals more physically solid
than a ghost but less so than a living
body there's also the infer but but
that's hardly a resurrection the
inferius is a corpse that has been
reanimated by dark wizard spells it is
not alive it is merely used like a
puppet to do the Wizard's bidding
healing cursed wounds although there are
healing spells and magical remedies
within the Wizarding World that can cure
a variety of ailments it should be
mentioned that there are limitations to
what magic can heal especially when it
comes to Cursed wounds in the Harry
Potter story there are a variety of
characters that sustained every
reversible injuries such as Madi Moody
George Weasley and even Dumbledore had
these cursed injuries been treatable
madii wouldn't have lost his eye George
wouldn't have lost his ear and Dore may
not have lost his life cloning to an
extent this one sort of falls under the
category of Life mentioned above the
concept of cloning isn't really explored
in the Harry Potter series and as far as
we can tell there is no indication that
creating identical copies of living
beings is a possibility within the known
magical framework the duplication of
individuals through magical means such
as poly juice potion allows for
temporary impersonation but does not
involve the creation of independent and
identical clones now I know what you're
thinking what about the much younger
version of Voldemort AKA Tom Riddle in
the Chamber of Secrets wasn't that a
clone well not quite yes at one stage
there would have been two Voldemort
present in the world but no the new
Voldemort wouldn't be a of the old
Voldemort the two would still share a
life force and so the destruction of one
could mean the destruction of the other
however the most important thing to
remember is that the present day
Voldemort would be far too arrogant to
accept that another version of him
exists in the world one who is his equal
to quote Highlander there can only be
one the soul the concept of the soul is
explored in the Harry Potter series
quite a lot particularly through
Voldemort's attempts to split his soul
and create Haw rugs
however the idea of completely regaining
or restoring a damaged or fragmented
soul is not addressed as a possibility
the process of fragmenting the soul is
depicted as irreversible and morally
reprehensible with severe consequences
for those who engage in such dark magic
and that concludes my list of the
limitations of magic I'm sure I've left
some things out of my discussion here so
please do comment any limitations of
magic that come to your minds down below
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to
[Music]
live